dave gabe congratulations you've made it
into the final round of this competition
now we're sending you back to your home
for us to recreate an iconic weapon from
history
the yadagon
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days good luck
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been assigned to make a yadagon i
don't know how to spell yadagon but here
i am making one
i've never made a blade this long and
i've never made one that requires such
an ornate handle so i'm nervous
this is going to have to chop through a
pig a thigh bone maybe try to cut
through will's biceps i don't know i'm
gonna make it to cut
i think i've got the curve right
i think i'm sitting pretty
gabe my competitor is a very competent
smith so hopefully i'll have a blade
that will stand up and equal or surpass
his
very important to get the rough shape
today if i do not get the rough shape
knocked out today then that'll throw the
rest of the four days way behind
i don't have a power hammer or a forging
press so i have a lot of work ahead
this is my power hammer here
i think i'm the underdog
dave's got the upper hand he's been
doing it for a lot longer
it's his to lose i think and i hope i'm
gonna come in there and sneak and take
it from him i really like the shape
dave you're going down buddy
today the plan is to make my mokume
billet for the bolsters and the
ornamentation that goes on the side of
the blade
mokume technique in japanese means wood
grain metal it's laminated nickel silver
and copper and i'm squeezing them
together under high heat and they should
bind to create an interesting pattern
and that's steel
all right that's for later
it's quite time consuming but i think
the end product will be worth it
assuming it takes
that's hot
now i see if i've got a viable billet
yes
not molten also a good sign this better
be worth it
one thing i'm concentrating on the most
today is making sure everything is
symmetrical and getting ready for heat
treat feel a little nervous have some
things out of whack and it'll pull
that's one way you can cause warps
but i'm praying and hoping that's not an
issue
hmm
she has developed
i have a nice warp i don't have time to
make another blade i have to fix this
warp all right have no shot at winning
i'm going to clamp the blade in a
position so that the warp is over
corrected and hopefully it'll fix itself
in the temper otherwise i have no idea
what i'm gonna do
the mochamade came out great it was
worth it and yesterday i quenched the
blade and it came out straight and hard
today i'll start working on the ebony
handle so that
to that
i chose ebony because it's really pretty
wood the material's a little brittle but
i think it should be just fine i'm not
really sure if i got this thing fitted
properly i'm gonna hope for the best
right now
success
i would like the test to be on a banana
a nice soft banana but i suspect it's
going to be a giraffe or a fire hydrant
or a cuckoo clock i don't know what
they're going to come up with i hope it
does well
i fixed the warp as best as i possibly
could
goal for the day is to be dialed in on
the handle i'm going with this marble
wood it's already square just got some
width so that i can sculpt in the ears
[Music]
we are
all together
this sword i have dubbed dumbo because
it looks like an elephant
everything's come together it's
something i'm proud of
let's go whack something shall we
it's pretty clean cut
call that a day
late smith to see what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do i'll take
your yachtagon and deliver slashes and
thrust on this ballistics dummy dave
you're first are you ready yes sir let's
do this
i'm so nervous right now and i'm just
hoping my blade will perform well
it's got bowels dropping out everywhere
let's talk about your weapon dave
it follows the feel of a yadagon that's
supposed to be light and deadly
the edge you have here is sharp where
which curved into lacery
your yada gone will kill
thank you very much
all right gabe your turn you ready go
nuts man let's do this
dave's blade performed seemingly really
well guts falling out of the thing and
blood everywhere so a little
nerve-wracking knowing they'll have to
at least measure up to that
[Applause]
[Music]
all right gabe
it is so light
it really feels like it's not there it's
almost scary
when i thrust it penetrates easily and
slashes down
overall sir your blade
will kill thank you
i think we cut quite similarly i would
prefer to be a head but right now i feel
like we're neck and neck
all right gentlemen this is the strength
test
to test the strength of your weapon i'll
be chopping into these bones six times
dave you're up first
hacking bone is a very difficult thing
to do with a thin edge i'm aghast
knowing what's going to be coming
all right david that's a tough test
those are very thick bones but what
we've got going on here is a lot of
chipping and distortion on your blade
we've also got
a major crack in your handle it runs
right up through the pins
all right gabe your turn you ready for
this you're nuts
[Music]
okay gabe
the convex edge you've got on here it's
pretty much the perfect edge for a test
like this
sharp
and strong
i can feel
just the smallest amount
of a roll
nicely done find you
all right gentlemen next up the
sharpness test for that i'll give it to
doug
i have edge damage i have handle damage
it's
disheartening
but it's not over yet
bladesmiths to see if your blade is
still sharp i will take your weapon and
slash through these silks
if your blade is still sharp it should
cut cleanly if not it may rip or tear or
worse
do nothing
dave you're up first you ready yes sir
let's do this
[Music]
all right
i love the balance of your blade i like
the way it curves in
but you can really feel the edges now
it's serrated
it hangs up with silk but then on the
last piece just when it's nice and taut
we can lacerate and cut through it
overall
your blade will still cut thank you
all right gabe it's your turn you ready
i'm ready let's do this
[Music]
all right gabe your blade is so light
you're barely like cutting through air
i glided through this lacerated and of
course in the finishing cuts here
cut easily through that silk
it cuts
good job thank you very much
bladesmiths you both created remarkable
finale weapons but in this arena of
competition there can only be one forged
and fired champion
and that champion is
gabe congratulations you are the fortune
fire champion
dave your weapon did not make the cut
dave you brought us an outstanding
weapon that yadagon is fantastic but
during the strength test we lost
structural integrity in the edge of your
blade and in the handle with both scales
fracturing and those are things we
obviously can't overlook so that's why
we're going to let you go sure
dave please surrender your weapon it's
exactly what i expected it was very
difficult testing but i'm still the guy
with the cracked edge and the broken
handle
it's like going out with a beautiful
blonde
and finding out she has b.o
and my blade
has b.o
gabe congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion and will be receiving
a check for ten thousand dollars good
job
i've never seen anybody less stoked
about getting 10 grand in my entire life
would you please present that weapon to
the judges it feels great to be the
foreign fire champion but i'll do my
celebrating behind closed doors
i felt like i was the underdog but
underdogs win sometimes i guess
[Music]
you